hello everyone and welcome to the final
of Dylan Doris a be rapid challenge it's
the new Luba vs. Hikaru Nakamura after
those wild the semi-final matches Dougal
vs. ding Liron and magnets vs. Nakamura
now we are in the finals and before we
check out the game ad this is Game one
of their first match here are their
here's their head-to-head score up until
this point so there we have it in
classical game seeker Nakamura tied the
dub of zero to zero with two draws
however in ink if we check out only
rapid slash exhibition games Hikaru
Nakamura defeated Daniel Lugo four to
one with 5 rows so in classical it's a
tie but in a rapid and exhibition games
Nakamura has the lead so without further
ado let's check it out as already game 1
is very very exciting yeah now do but
with the white pieces opened with the d4
with Knight to f6 by Hikaru c4 e6 Knight
to f3 and d5 we go into the Queens
gambit declined Knight to c3 and Bishop
to e7 so similar like to what Magnus and
Nakamura played however do go develops
his Bishop to g5 not there for like
Magnus did and okay we have h 6
challenging the bishop bishop to h4 end
and nakamura castles we have Queen to c2
and c5 now striking in the center D
captures on c5 and the D captures on c4
with III by dubov preparing to recapture
the pawn here and there is one game in
the database where Queen to a5 was
played in I was played in the game
Petrosyan verses later in the 1983
Moscow Championship the game ended in a
draw however here night the a6 by
Nakamura and it is a new move so already
as of move 9 we have a completely new
game preparing just that recapture on c5
so with Bishop captures on c4 and Knight
captures on c5 with castles by dubov
and a6 now preparing b5 to start the
expansion in the center or b6 for that
matter if you want to wait would be 5
will group F to d1 challenging the Queen
and the Queen that EA now and the bishop
back to e2 so now b5 will not come with
tempo we have beasts
instead Nakamura prepares to fianchetto
the light square bishop here and now
before I just forcing that nice to move
away night C to d7 in now Knights to d4
getting getting the nice tour to a nicer
central square also freeing up the f3
square for the bishop so you can utilize
the bishop on this long diagonal Bishop
to be 7 by Nakamura and now Queen to
beat you with Queen to be 2 you are
preparing b5 which will grab a lot of
space on the Queen side however it will
give up the control of the c5 square so
it's a it's a double edged the idea and
the camera goes for Luke to c8 it gets
his rook to D to the open sea file and
now not rook a to C 1 but we're at this
instant b5 so like we said this will
could pose problems for example if you
allow this capture then the beast
exponent will be very weak or if he carl
traits here but Hikaru instead just goes
a 5 he says ok I'm not worried about
this and I now get to the c5 square for
my night my bishop and whatever I choose
and now the it seems like the critical
idea here is Knight to c6 for Du Bois
and it's quite the idea it involves a
temporary pawn sacrifice with captures
captures and characters however you will
get a lot of development in for example
Bishop to b5 now you have to be careful
as there will be some pressure going on
here so rook c7 outbursts of g3
attacking the rook and let's say e 5 and
now comes Luke 8 to see one point is on
the next movie we'll capture here and
you will be able to regain your pawn for
example if Queen c8 then you get Bishop
captures on d7 and now you cannot
capture with the night to keep on
defending d5 pawn because 95 wins the
game for white if you capture with the
road and first Knight captures with
check and only then you recapture
so what you would have to do is capture
with the rook and then Bishop captures
on e5 wins back your pawn and the game
just continues so this seems to be the
critical idea Knights the c6 however
Deauville goes for Knight to a4 puts
pressure on the b6 pawn and opens opens
up the C file Knights the d5 by Hikaru
and now Bishop cap for Sonny 7 here he
caught off for some trades on e7 and
he's asking do you want to go back with
Bishop to g3
after which I will probably shift my
best up over to f6 to grab hold of this
diagonal so do both decides to trade
here with Bishop character Sonny 7 Queen
captures and Bishop to f3 now and gets
the bishop to this diagonal and now
Knight the c5 finally the c5 square get
occupied by Hikaru's Knight also rook
the c4 was a very nice idea here as the
knight is undefended and you don't
really have a good square for the knight
you cannot retreat the night and you
cannot defend the night with anything
simply simply doesn't work if Queen to
b3 you can just kick the Queen away with
with a rook the b4 and on the other hand
we again get this line where again you
have to sacrifice a pawn temporarily
captures captures and captures and then
you would get some like Bishop captures
on d5e characters and Rohde characters
so again it was a possibility for black
where again you end up with this
position with 2 points against one on
the Queen side however nakamoto goes for
nice the c5 instead and now we have
Knight captures on c5 you cannot go for
a bunch of characters on d5 fall by
winning the pawn because if Bishop
characters just Knight captures attacks
the Queen and you will now lose a piece
because on the next move you also lose
the bishop if you try some like Queen b3
to attack the night first night c5
attack the Queen and only then do you
recapture the bishop here and you are up
a piece so after Knight c5 we have
Knight captures on c5 by dubov rook
captures on c5 and now Knight to c6
again going for this for this sacrifice
idea so with the idea that if captures
captures and captures you can just
captures captures and of course captures
win back your pawn however now camera
played Bishop captures and c6 b captures
and now not captures right away but
first Queen to c7
not allowing this capture on d5 as for
the moment both of the rook and upon
defend the night so it seems like on the
next move nakamora will just win a full
full pawn so rook
8 to c1 do what doesn't really have a
choice here and now Queen captures and
c6 do boom now trades rook captures
Queen captures and Bishop captures on d5
with each
actress and Aoife and rook to c1 and
Nakamura is now up upon but duo will try
to play against these two pawns
especially if you can maybe get a
foreign to keep the phone and b6 should
be should be playable and okay Queen to
d6 play Nakamura and now g3 we have
worked the d8 now preparing to push the
pawn to d4 and the Queen to b5 now with
ideas of maybe rook to c6 fall by you
know just gobbling up all of the Queen
side point we have d4 and now rook the
c6 is definitely an idea here however if
you go look the c6 then Queen to e7 and
you don't really you don't really have
time to go for this point as D captures
an e3 is coming and even after captures
and captures you again don't have time
to go after the pawn so black would just
be better if you go after the pond and
rogue d1 check King here and Queen check
will just be over you have to go to h3
now rogue d5 the Queen covers g2 this
will just be a quick death for white so
after d4 we have it captures on d4 sorry
let's just show it he captures on d4
first Queen capture Stanley for end only
now rook the c6 baidu book however
Nakamura makes sure that that's never
even a threat he just goes Quinta e4 now
of course any captures will be met with
rook to d1 which will just instantly win
the game since the Queen covers the g2
square so look back to c1 by do both and
now Queen to f3 again with some ideas of
rook to d1 check also maybe the row can
come to d2 to put pressure on f2 it
depends on what white plays so Queen
back the b1 not allowing this trade and
now not doing any roof lifts because the
rook to see it will just be deadly since
the Queen covered the h7 square so first
g6 Hikaru make some room for the king
and now h4 by duble we have worked a d6
guarding the pawn and well black that
really doesn't have any problems here
with Queen to a-1 now threatening check
and after the King moves rook to e8
checkmate since the Queen now coverage
the h8 square so King to h7 Nakamura
doesn't allow this and of course if you
go for a rook lived and ruled e1 check
is just game over
so Queen back to be won by Dube of n now
h5 with
t1 and now comes a for my Nakamura now
he will start to push his his pawns we
have Queen to b4 Dubeau goes after the
pawn now but now Nakamura just goes for
the trade looked a d1 you don't have
time to capture because of characters so
dubov has to trade captures captures
with check King h2 and now Queen to c2
defending this pawn putting pressure on
both of these pawns do both goes for
Queen captures and b6 which guards the
DF to point but now Queen captures on a
2 so now we're in a queen important game
where Nakamura is up upon and usually
Queen opponent games are super
complicated however here where black
king is very safe the Queen guards the
f7 pawn you just basically have to move
the Queen and start pushing your upon
it's not really not really a thriller
but you also of course have to be very
careful so double-click Queen to f6
but Nakamura just takes it away of
course every Queen trade is favorable
only to Nakamura Queen back to c3
preventing a three but now Queen back to
be three this time with tempo as the
White has to again make a Queen move so
Queen to f6 and now a three the Queen
again nicely defends the f7 pawn and now
dubov is without options he has to go
all-in
g4 but now Quinta es hora Quinta a6
again putting pressure on the pawn here
on the Queen so Queen to f3 hoping for
maybe ideas like Queen captures on g4
and then Queen captures here which would
result in a draw by repetition after
Queen f7 Queen FA to check but after
Queen to f3 Nakamura just played a two
and it was in this position that done
you'll do of resign the game yes there
is nothing more to be done here whatever
you you play it will be very very easy
to to get the point into the game let's
say if you try something like Queen to
c3 the guard did this then black has a
variety of options of how to deal with
this you can capture on g4 you can
pretty much do whatever you want you're
gonna be up another pawn and then it's
just even more downhill from there sir
after a 2 double resigns in the game one
of their first match goes to Hikaru
Nakamura who is one step closer to
winning the the finals
deal indoors a b-rabbit challenge sure
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank eval
upon earth on Cana party Pele I try
gross Ashfaq Ahmad Gabriel Gabriel look
and blocks flourish for a contribution
to my channel thank you I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Lindor s
every rabbit challenge the finals until
it finishes of course checking up on
your wonderful suggestions as well and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day